- Six months ago when
we first realized it,
if I touched what I'm touching right now,
the way I'm touching right
now, it was massive pain.
- That's not good.
Is it not what you were
expecting, to chatting to?
- No, I like this stuff,
I'm super into it.
Let me show you, let
me show you, like this.
What do you think of that,
Babeth, does that hurt?
- [Erik] If you break his neck you know...
- Or are you good?
- Yeah, yeah that hurts.
- That hurts right?
- When you went lower, yeah.
- And I'm not really, this right?
- Yeah.
- Erik, lemme see yours.
No, it's fine it's fine!
No, no come on, stop.
- I don't even like massages.
- I don't give a shit.
(bass heavy music)
(ethereal music)
- What's up vlog?
Here in London.
Just got in from L.A., we're
headed to a client meeting.
Just wrapping up, been
fighting a cold all week.
So, that's been interesting, kind of ...
But, lot of good stuff,
super fired up for 18.
Super focused.
If you've noticed, less posts on Instagram
the last week or two, just really in
CEO mode.
Feeling really good about
that, got a lot done
in the last couple of weeks of the year.
Headed now to see a senior client.
Got client meetings here in London
until tonight, the holiday party.
Babin you should interview
peeps for the holiday party.
That'll be a good episode.
(ethereal music)
- What up vlog, it's me, taking control.
Babin's been doing a great
job behind the scenes.
Most of this episode's
gonna be the holiday party,
I'm sure he's gonna transition to it now.
But, we've been doing a shit load
of meetings, it's going super well.
I don't know what Babin's been doing.
What have you been doing?
- Standing around.
- No but really.
- I'm just kinda standing around.
- Fuck.
- (laughs)
- So, this is unbelievable to me.
I've had a bad back my whole life,
cause I hurt it at 18 at
my dad's liquor store.
That's right, out of everything
I've ever done in my life,
in the last three weeks, six weeks,
there's this stick that Erik
saw me using with my trainer
in Sweden, Sweden?
Where were we?
Stockholm.
Rolling, soft tissue work, like
tissue quality,
has changed my life,
and when I think about
all the massages, all the
stretching, all the working out,
that Jordan, taking what
is a stick, in essence,
and like rolling my
adduct, rolling, rolling.
I literally tell Jordan every two days
the world needs to know
about, I feel like there's
no conversation.
Neck, neck, has been huge
cause I travel so much
and sleep, I don't know if
you've started feeling this.
Like when you sleep in awkward ...
- Even if it's fully laid back,
it's never been comfortable.
- Ready for this?
Six months ago when we first realized it,
if I touched what I'm touching right now,
the way I'm touching right
now, it was massive pain.
- That's not good.
Is this not what you were
expecting, to be chatting to.
- No I like this stuff, I'm super into it.
Let me show you, let me show you.
Like this, what do you
think of that Babeth?
Does that hurt?
- [Erik] If you break
his neck, you know ...
- Or are you good?
- Yeah, yeah, that hurts.
- That hurts right?
- When you went lower, yeah.
- And I'm not really, this right?
- Yeah.
- Erik, lemme see yours.
No, it's fine, it's fine!
No, no, come on, stop.
- I don't even like massages.
- I don't give a shit, let
me just see it real quick.
Let me, no actually.
- I've never seen a guy so uncomfortable.
What about this, Erik?
Does that hurt or no?
- No.
- Yeah, you don't have
neck problems do you?
Let me see.
- This is like.
- I wanna see.
- Like I put it out there.
Holy shit, dude.
- Without any problems.
- Let me see yours, Erik.
One more time, we need it for the vlog.
This was really good.
- You're like easy.
- Erik, lemme see yours, come on.
Cause yours is really bad, right?
My jeans are so tight.
- [Erik] But I know I'm gonna lose.
- This is incredible.
I used to not be able to, I
used to be here when I started.
- We're not bending our knees right?
- [Gary] No bending knees.
- Damn, come on!
- You can go further.
- You're not even trying.
- You're not trying, you're
doing it for effect, go.
- This is as far as I go.
- (laughs)
- [Gary] You know that's
hamstrings, right?
- I know.
- Yeah.
- It's great.
- What about you, Babeth?
Come on.
No, no, you bent your knees
a little bit too much.
Start again.
No, stop bending your knees bro.
- I'm trying!
- [Gary] Kick your ass back out.
- I'm locked in.
- [Gary] Okay, pretty good man.
Why is yours so good?
- It's, I can feel it's tight.
- [Gary] No, that was pretty
good, did you see, Erik?
He's a disaster.
(ethereal music)
- I'm sure you get it all the
time, much respect, brother.
There, I hopefully can get that energy.
- Thank you.
- No, seriously.
- What's your name?
- Ian.
- Ian, thanks for saying what's up.
- You know what, blessings brother.
You spend a lot of time with people.
- Thank you brother, have a good holiday.
- Amazing, you too.
- Thank you man.
- So we're here on the
boat, which has become
a London office tradition,
and it's going super well.
Having meeting with Raiza, on my team.
I don't think you caught that, did you
catch any of that feed, bro?
Bad job, Babin.
The BJB is my favorite,
the "bad job Babin."
Anyway, planning a lot of
the Asia stuff with Raiza.
Now we're about to give the awards,
which the London office does,
so I'm excited for that.
Just a productive day.
- Best ex-pat to integrate
into British culture.
Let's see who that is.
Okay, and the winner is, Claire!
(crowd cheers)
- Yeah.
- And the correct pronunciation is gif.
(crowd roars)
- Brett!
(cheers)
- The hard work, the efforts, the passion
that everybody put into 2017,
you guys saw an email
from me a couple weeks ago
just alluding to how
excited about 2018 I was,
we've had an enormous amount
of pretty substantial wins
that we'll start announcing
over the next couple weeks,
which is great, but it's funny
I got to say a very similar
thing to Chattanooga
from a different angle.
When I look across at what we're doing,
and I think about 2017
as I think everybody does
this time of year you start
to reminisce a little bit.
Something very exciting happened
in London this year for me.
What's really exciting to
me, and I think a lot about
what Erik and Ryan and Jenna put into it,
and the rest of you, the
thing that excites me the most
is the great flaw.
This is gonna be very narrow,
I know not everybody's
into Star Wars, but it just came out.
Much like the Death Star,
where there's this one random
completely ridiculous flaw in the system
of the ultimate machine, I
really do thing of Vayner media
ironically in a Death Star way,
I really do think we're gonna win.
I do wanna destroy the world.
(crowd laughs)
So, congrats, you're part of it!
I'm just so grateful,
and so thankful because
what we've been able to do,
and lemme rephrase, what
you've been able to do
in this office, on the thing
that I'm most fearful of,
which is how do you guys
play with each other
when you're on different
sides of the ball,
has given me enormous
confidence and has made me
greedy on our capabilities
over the next decade
and definitely going into the new year.
I will tell you that the
last hundred or so days,
150 days of this office,
re-setting and getting
their North star, and working
collaboratively in this world,
is a bigger feat, and
a more impactful feat
than you realize, because it allows a CEO
who's disproportionately navigating
a lot of excitement on
what we're capable of,
and so, I thank you guys very, very much.
From the department heads,
to the person that started
the most recently, that's on this boat,
it's a very, very, very big deal.
It is truly our kryptonite, it is truly
our only vulnerability, because
everything else I truly
believe, is on its way.
We are on the right side of history.
We do things that we believe in.
For me, holiday parties
are easy, it's fun,
everybody's unwinding,
but I pay attention,
I've been to about 30 of em at this point.
I'm very, very, very happy with
the tone of this office,
with the ambition.
I hope you enjoy the rest
of the night, thanks.
(applause)
- Hey.
- [Passerby] New York City!
- Yeah.
- I was totally disappointed.
- Really?
- [Passerby] It all goes
much better when you have...
in a U.S. city.
- That is the most ludicrous shit
I've ever heard in my life.
- Oh, I'm sorry, I'm a Jets
fan, look at the Vikings.
Where are we going?
- I like the Vikings.
- Oh okay, then I retract that statement.
- (laughs) Are you a Vikings fan?
- Yeah.
- I'm rooting for them heavily.
- Let's go Case right?
- Casey Keeton (laughs), I love him.
Casual 14 hours in London.
Just got a bunch of bad news from
some business losses,
so I'm fuckin pissed,
for about another 13 seconds.
That's where I'm at.
11:38, walking in the cold in London,
fuckin angry (laughs).
(inspirational music)